Hallo Lara, wie geht’s?
Schön, dass du gekommen bist.
Hallo Simon, mir geht’s super, danke.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ich bin schon sehr gespannt auf das Spiel.
Ja, ich auch. Ich konnte den ganzen
Tag an nichts anderes denken.
Komm doch rein.
Sag mal Simon, schaust du nur Fussballoder spielst du auch gern selbst?
Ich liebe es sowohl Fussball zu
schauen als auch Fussball zu spielen.
Früher habe ich lange Fussball im Verein gespielt.
Mit 14 habe ich aber Schmerzen im rechtenKnie bekommen und musste aufhören.
Hätte ich keine Schmerzen gehabt, wäre
ich bestimmt Fussball-Profi geworden.
Oh je, das tut mir sehr leid für dich.
Du wärst bestimmt sehr gerne Profi geworden.
Ja! Wäre ich Fussball-Profi geworden, hätteich viele berühmte Spieler kennengelernt.
Ich wäre auch viel gereist und
hätte in vielen Stadien gespielt.
Was denkst du, wer das Spiel gewinnt?
Die Rotbären natürlich!
Wir haben ein gutes und erfahrenes Team.
Dieses Mal schaffen wir es
bestimmt bis ins Viertelfinale.
Mit ein bisschen Glück sogar bis ins Halbfinale.
Und dann weiss man ja nie, was passieren kann.
Ja das stimmt.
Turniere sind immer unberechenbar.
Manchmal muss man einfach etwas Glück haben.
Ja. Weisst du, wenn das Turnier
letztes Jahr gewesen wäre,
wäre ich an alle Spiele der Rotbären gegangen.
Jetzt habe ich aber einen neuen Job
angefangen und kann nicht an die Spiele gehen.
Ja, das ist wirklich schade.
Aber wenigstens können wir
am Fernseher mitfiebern.
Ja, das stimmt. Und das in bester Gesellschaft.
Yeeeeeeeeee!!!!!!! Juhuuuuuuuu!!
Moment Lara, das Tor zählt nicht. Es war Abseits.
Oh nein, das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ich war schon im Freudentaumel!
Schade. Hätte der Spieler den Pass eineSekunde früher gespielt, hätte das Tor gezählt.
Dann hätten wir uns zusammen freuen können.
Neinnnnnn, das gibt es doch nicht!
Wie konnte das nur passieren!!!!
Oh schade! Aber es bleibt
ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Sie werden bestimmt bald wieder ausgleichen.
Das macht mich wütend!
Hätten die Verteidiger besser
aufgepasst, wäre dieses Tor nie passiert.
Komm schon Simon, abwarten und Teetrinken, wie man so schön sagt.
Ich bin so nervös, ich muss ein Bier trinken.
Haha. Ja! Oder noch besser:
Trink einen Shot Tequila!
Oh ja, gute Idee. Tequila beruhigt mich sicher.
Oh nein, ich habe keinen Tequila mehr.
Wir haben ihn letztes Wochenende
bei der Grillparty getrunken.
Hätten wir diese Grillparty nicht gefeiert,
hätten wir die Flasche Tequila nicht getrunken.
Dann hätte ich jetzt etwas für meine Nerven.
Jaaaaaaa, endlich!!! Ich hätte fast
nicht mehr an das Tor geglaubt.
Siehst du Simon, ich habe dir ja gesagt,
dass wir noch ein Tor schiessen werden.
Jetzt kommt gleich noch das Zweite!
Ja, du hattest recht! Aber wir hatten etwas Glück.
Wäre die Nachspielzeit
nicht fünf Minuten gegangen,
dann hätten wir das Tor nicht
vor der Pause geschossen.
Lara, sag mal, seit wann interessierst
du dich eigentlich für Fussball?
Weisst du, früher hat mich
Fussball null interessiert.
Aber meine Schwester hatte einmal
einen Freund, der Fussballer war.
Er hat für den FC Adler gespielt.
Also ging ich ab und zu mit ihr an die Spiele.
Im Stadion hat mich die Atmosphäre total gepackt.
Seither bin ich ein grosser Fussball-Fan!
Hätte meine Schwester den
Fussballer nicht als Freund gehabt,
wäre ich nie an die Spiele gegangen und hättesomit auch weiterhin kein Interesse am Fussball.
Das ist interessant! Ich freue
mich, dass dir Fussball gefällt.
So können wir uns auch andere
Spiele zusammen anschauen.
Ja! Allerdings ist es viel unterhaltsamer,
dich während des Spiels zu beobachten.
Bin ich denn so emotional?
Ja, aber keine Sorge. Das gefällt mir!
Jaaaaaaa!!! Da ist es! Was habe ich dir gesagt?
Jaaaaaaa, du bist eine Wahrsagerin!
Naja, Wahrsagerin nicht,
aber ich hatte es im Gefühl!
Ich habe ja schon viele Spiele von den
Rotbären gesehen und kenne unsere Qualitäten.
Hätte ich nicht so viele Spiele gesehen,
hätte ich auch nicht an den Sieg geglaubt.
Ein Sieg ist es noch nicht.
Es sind ja noch 10 Minuten zu spielen.
Kein Problem. Die lassen jetzt nichts anbrennen.
Oh nein! Was ist denn da passiert?
Das gibt’s doch nicht. Die haben wieder gepennt!
Moment, schau mal, der VAR wird konsultiert.
Yeeeeeee!!!!! Das Tor zählt nicht.
Gott sei Dank! Ich habe schon die Krise bekommen.
Hahaha, ja, ich habe es an
deinem roten Kopf bemerkt.
War das knapp.
Hätte der Spieler den Ball eine Sekundefrüher gespielt, hätte das Tor jetzt gezählt.
Jaaaa, wir haben gewonnen. Juhuuuuu
Jaaaa, wir sind eine Runde weiter!
Soso, hätte die Rotbären nicht gewonnen,
hättest du mich wohl nie geküsst.
Oh Lara, die Gans hätte 10:0 gewinnen
können und ich hätte dich trotzdem geküsst!